you have to love what you do you have to
love what you do the most important rule
in business in life is you have to love
what you do how can you expect to do
great things if you hate what you do you
will not have an impact you will not
accomplish anything major if your stock
doing things that you hate with people
who you hate its basics and too many
entrepreneurs start a business just
trying to make a bunch of money and they
never end up making it because they
don't love what they do you have to love
your business I got a question for one
of my newsletter readers love you guys
addisu who wrote in the say dear Evan I
always read your inspirational emails i
love them and sometimes even post them
on social media sites like Facebook
thank you very much let me tell you
about myself I was government employed
for and then three months ago I resigned
and not working with an American company
I get a much better salary commission to
my previous job but one thing is I'm not
energetic I don't know why I have a
dream to be a good entrepreneur the
bright future I need your advice Thanks
you're not happy because you're not an
entrepreneur you want to be an
entrepreneur this is the life you want
for yourself and you're stuck in this
job that's why you're not happy you're
not doing something that you love and
it's not about money you know you give
somebody a raise you give somebody a
bonus and they're happy for about a week
and then their life falls back to
average what people really want is to
feel like they're doing meaningful work
people even take less money because they
feel like they're doing meaningful work
Steve Jobs is a multi-millionaire in his
early 20s and he kept working till the
day he died at Apple because he felt
like he was doing meaningful work he
loved what he did it's like if you're
married to somebody who you hate how do
you expect to be happy right how do you
expect to be happy in life when you're
married to somebody who you hate it's
the same thing if you have a job and you
want to be an entrepreneur how do you
expect to be motivated how do you expect
to have energy when you wake up every
day you go to this company that you
don't want to work for now I know
certain the business is hard it's hard
it's scary it's it's risky you know most
people fail at it but you have to start
at least to know at least to know if
this was meant for you there's nothing
worse than living with regret then
thinking you could have done this great
thing but you never had the courage to
stand up and do it so start small make
it less scary make it less risky start
small do something every single day to
get this I business idea of yours off
the ground 15 minutes 20 minutes 30
minutes 60 minutes whatever you have
spend that time to start building a
little bit of momentum for your company
when you earn your first dollar from
your own business is such a great
feeling and I want you to experience
that and to know that you're helping
have an impact now on people's lives
through your own company and build it up
to the point where eventually you can
quit your job and go with your business
it doesn't have to be super risky or
super scary but you have to start
because you just sitting at your job
dreaming of starting your own business
is going to lead to a path of regret and
constantly beating down on yourself I
not have any energy and not being
motivated and you'll find as soon as you
start doing something on your own as
soon as you start chasing your dream
even though it's in little chunks as
soon as you feel like there's a hope
right there's something to look forward
to it's amazing how much energy you'll
have and how motivated you'll feel so
start now start small chase your dream
but start now believe
for those of you watching like the video
you can support me by clicking on the
link in the description leave a comment
let me know what you think and click on
the face subscribe to my channel thank
you so much I'll see you soon